[Musique]
deux cents ans après sa découverte la
rose de bourbon prend racine dans l'un
des plus vieux jardin créole de la
réunion à mascara pour célébrer cet
anniversaire et valoriser ce patrimoine
végétal derosier de bourbon sont mises
en terre une première plantation
symbolique sur cet espace qui
accueillera la future roseraie du jardin
botanique
on essaiera d'avoir une roseraie de
référence c'est à dire qu'avec les les
rosiers bourbon des rosiers anciens
également mais qui sont qui seront
validées qui sont identifiés ont fait un
inventaire actuellement tout autour de
l'île donc on aura une partie de ses
rosiers peut-être également des rosiers
importés de métropole mais voilà une
cinquantaine de variétés plusieurs
dizaines de d'individus sur sur cet
espace qu'on espère planté voilà très
prochainement une cinquantaine de
variétés de rosiers fleuriront dans
cette future roseraie avec une
collection unique de rose de bourbon la
roseraie portera le nom de marie thérèse
au nom de la roseraie symbolique parce
que ça va prendre le nom d'une personne
que des réunionnais connaissent ou
connaissent pas ça va permettre
justement à la faire connaître c'est
madame marie-thérèse de chateauvieux qui
était première de la réunion si nous
rose que beaucoup de réunionnais
connaissent peut-être pas donc
aujourd'hui ce sera l'occasion justement
de faire une plantation et ils pourront
venir visiter au jardin botanique
cette plantation et connaître la rose
bonbon le public est invité à découvrir
cette rose native de la réunion une
exposition réalisée par mascarin lui est
même consacré la rose bourbon patrimoine
de la réunion deux cents ans d'histoire
[Musique]